so I am lace I am gonna be presenting on
data DevOps for the modern data
warehouse and Azure so just a little bit
about me I'm a senior software engineer
as part of the commercial software
engineering team at Microsoft I am based
in Melbourne and my specialization is
around data specifically around spark
and data bricks so there's my github and
Twitter if you want to reach me
okay so agenda for today very simple so
I'll start up with an overview of the
modern data warehouse what this what is
this what kind of patterns are we
proposing from the Microsoft side and
also more importantly how you actually
operationalize a data pipeline and also
be talking about learnings that we we
found out along the way along the best
practices from working with customers
okay so modern data warehouse so before
I talk about actually the data
warehousing side of it I want to talk
about the analytics so from because this
is essentially you know why the reason
you actually do data warehousing so from
left to right we have descriptive
analytics which is essentially asks the
question what happened it answers the
question what happened essentially for
example your sales what was my sales
from the last month and then you have
diagnostic analytics which answers the
question why did it happen so perhaps my
sales for last month was quite low
because the specific store didn't
perform in in as expected and then we go
into the realm of predictive analytics
what what will happen in the future what
will my sales be in the next month or
the next quarter and finally we have
prescriptive analytics which meet which
tries to ask the question or answer the
question how can we make it happen
like what are the certain steps that we
can take in order to actually increase
sales for next quarter now you can
imagine as the value of these analytics
increase so that's the difficulty of
actually implementing these the first
two analytics have a very top-down
approach that is you typically start
with your fact and dimension tables the
reports that you have in mind that you
want to create and then you populate
this with data well the the previous the
the second two analytics has a very
bottom-up approach that is you don't
necessarily
know which datasets are going to be
useful for your machine learning models
perhaps that your data scientist has
tactics do some exploratory analysis so
you have to gather all this data so for
your data scientist to use and then
they'll probably figure out oh these are
the certain data sets we're going to be
reporting on so it's a very bottom-up
approach of actually building your data
pipelines the traditional data warehouse
would get you as far as the first two
analytics but really to get through all
the four analytics you have to have a
different pattern which we call the
modern data warehouse okay so the folks
who are coming from a data warehousing
background this should be very very
familiar you have your typical sources
from the from the left side which are
usually relational stores maybe a bunch
of flat files you have an extract
transform load process your ETL process
which basically transform it transforms
into your fact and dimension tables in
your warehouse you might have a staging
database in the middle that will
facilitate this this could be a schema
within your data warehouse and then
finally you have your reports which get
trans which get populated typically from
your data warehouse we want to transform
this this traditional data warehouse
into the modern data warehouse
architecture and the modern data
warehouse architecture fundamentally
revolves around the concept of a data
Lake which is essentially the response
to this this explosion of data sets
right so you no longer just have
relational data sets you have speech
video sound all of this coming into your
data Lake that relational based beta
pipeline no longer fits the bill
so typically you'd have some sort of
ingestion mechanism so something that
actually moves your data into your data
Lake you need to have some sort of
exploratory tool so that your data
scientist or your analyst can actually
query the stuff in your data Lake and of
course you need to have some sort of
analytics engine that so that you can
actually transform prep cleanse or train
machine learning models on top of your
data finally you need some sort of
serving layer so that the serving later
can be used by a downstream consumer
such as bi reporting and so on so this
is what it looks like
like when we slap on some adjure
services on top of the different
components here
so typically data/factory is your go to
ingestion mechanism along with your
orchestration mechanism and then you
have data bricks which is in a managed
patch is part platform that's available
in Azure where you can as for folks who
are familiar with spark spark is
essentially a distributed computing
engine which is a very very rich set of
API so you can use to transform your
data train machine learning models and
so on or you can use sequel data
warehouse with a technology called poly
base which essentially allows you to
query files that's sitting in your data
Lake that's if it was such a sequel
table and for prepping and training
there's also data breaks but there's
also HD inside if your company is
already quite invested in the Hadoop
ecosystem hdinsight is essentially a
managed to do platform that you can
utilize and for the serving layer
there's a myriad of different services
I've only added a few of them over here
so obviously the the most common one is
add your sequel there's also all the
major open-source databases that is
available on a past service like
Postgres and my sequel if that's what
you're using in your company and you
have the MPP file databases such as the
sequel data warehouse and all of this
fundamentally the one of the core
components of this sit on top of data
like Gen 2 so data like Gen 2 is a layer
on top of blob storage however it's
optimized for big data workloads it
gives you file level and folder level
security along with a hierarchical
namespace ok so there's much to be said
of how you actually structure your data
in your data Lake but I like to think
about them in different tiers and I've
seen this vary in one form in another in
different multiple customers so
typically you would structure your first
data the first sort of portion of your
data Lake dedicated to your bronze data
sets these are your raw unprocessed data
sets that you've just landed in your
data Lake and then you have your silver
data sets these are semi transformed
cleansed validated and usually typecast
already to the appropriate types and
they might be augmented maybe additional
features or columns might be added
and finally you have your gold datasets
these are your fact and dimensions these
are highly processed highly optimized
datasets that's ready for consumption
now to extend the analogy of a data Lake
your gold data sets is like your bottled
water your bottled water is clean it's
convenient and ready for use
now you imagine your business user
that's the folks who's gonna be using
your gold data sets but I get I get the
question why do we need a silver data
sense well that's for your data
scientist your data scientist typically
they don't want to be concerned with the
intricacies of the source systems like
your raw data sets they might still be
interested and they they don't really
want to do you know converting your your
string your date date strings into
actual dates they want some sort of
cleanse data set but they don't also
want a really processed data set they
still wants the normally set that exists
within that data set so the silver data
set is the perfect data sets for your
data scientists which bring me to the
first learning within the pipeline when
you build your pipelines it's validate
early in your pipeline what do I mean by
this so going through the analogy of the
T of the data tearing typically you one
valid ate around here right before you
go into your silver that way once it's
silver and onwards you know that you can
write code in your in your data
pipelines which have certain assumptions
with the data invariants that your
validation logics logic actually make
sure it holds so you can write logic at
this point so that any other code
downstream can make that assumption that
this for example column has this set and
set of codes win it these columns or it
will never be null and so on and so
forth and from this validation logic
typically you'd have some rows that
won't make through make through this
validation logic so you don't want to be
dropping your data you probably want to
sink this something some sort of
malformed record schema and you
obviously need to put on monitoring on
this so in case that this kind of blows
up for whatever reason okay so a
question for a question that I get a lot
is why not be valid
here before we even hit the Natalie well
we all know that code net always works
right well not really so the problem
with validating there is that you might
introduce a bug and then you essentially
tear down or potentially corrupt the
data sets in your data link so that
brings me to my second learning is
ensure your data pipeline is replayable
so going back to the data tiers your
bronze layer typically has almost zero
transformation it's just a copy over to
your data lake that way you are the the
likelihood of introducing a bug which
corrupts your data is very very minimal
it's a append-only immutable store of
data and then your silver data sets
that's when you start your
transformation your validation and your
goal is your highly optimized transform
data set so that way if you do introduce
a bug and I am pretty sure it will
happen as we know we're all not perfect
and you do corrupt your silver and gold
you can just replay your your pipeline
and then repopulate your silver and gold
that way you're not dropping data and
you can actually reconstruct your silver
and gold data sets okay for the demo I
am gonna be using this publicly
available API which has been gracefully
provided by the Melbourne government so
the Melbourne government actually has a
bunch of sensors parking sensors spread
across the CBD and these are in ground
sensors which detect if there's a
vehicle part or not and it's all
available in API if you're interested
you can go to that link right here and
for the demo that I'll be presenting
I'll be using this API as my source data
now the details of the data is not
necessarily important I do want everyone
to be focusing more on the architecture
of the data pipeline so here's a sample
of the modern data warehouse patterns
actually in a concrete data pipeline so
from left to right we have the parking
service we have a copy job that actually
lands it into the landing area or a
landing schema and then we have a
Clemson standardized job which takes
this this raw data entrance and cleanses
it and transforms it into what we call
the silver data sets
in this case I'm calling that interim
schema and there might be some malformed
records that come along so I put my bad
data in that schema and then I have a
second transform job which takes this
transforms it to the data where a schema
and finally I have a pulley base I'm
using poly base to actually take the
data that's sitting in data Lake and
move it into sequel data warehouse all
of this is orchestrated using data
Factory
okay so let's jump into our demo okay so
I am here in data Factory and as you can
see this data pipeline is very similar
to the one that I've shown in my diagram
and for those who are new to data
factory data this is the data factory
workspace or wizard if you want to call
it and you have a number of activities
here that you can just drag and drop and
author your pipelines all in this wizard
so the first step in my pipeline I'm
just setting a variable called set in
file folder this is just a timestamp so
I'm stamping my folders and then I'm
using a copy date activity which
basically reads from that REST API and
then sinks into the data Lake and I'm
using that timestamp right here which is
the file folder the timestamp which will
be the name of the file folder it sinks
into so if we have a look at that in
data Lake it looks like this so we have
the data Lake in the landing schema
which is time-stamped in this folder and
we have do JSON files sitting in data
Lake
nice and easy next job we have the
standardized data job which is
essentially a data bricks job it calls a
data bricks notebook and the beauty of
this is that it spins up a spark cluster
when it gets triggered and then pairs it
down afterwards so it's quite cost
efficient in that regard that you don't
have a 24-hour spark cluster running and
as you can see I am calling this part
this notebook in this path let's
navigate to that notebook so this is in
the data breaks workspace if you use
Jupiter notebooks before it's very
similar it's a notebook sort of it way
of coding
and I'm I'm using Python but data bricks
can support Scala sequel and are so you
can write your data transformation in
those three four languages okay the
first bit of code I have here is just a
way of parameterizing notebook so that
this notebook actually knows where which
which files to actually pick up and read
and then I'm just setting that file path
right here and this is the bulk of the
code so the first line here is I'm I'm
importing a Python package that I
Britian and I'll get into that in later
parts of the demo but essentially that
Python package has a set of functions
that I'm calling in this set of code in
this code I'm retrieving the schema that
it expects I'm using a spark dot read
and then filtering out the bad rows that
don't conform to the schema that I
expect into this file folder and then
once I have my data frame I'm calling
standardized parking Bay and
standardized sensor data passing in the
raw data frame and along with other
variables and it outputs a tuple of data
frames the first the first data frame is
your good rose and the second data frame
are your bad rows these are my malformed
records and then the good rows go into
my interim schema and then the bad rows
go into the malformed schema so nice and
simple just read transform and load now
the next step is my transform data the
transform data is very similar I have a
parameter which just identifies which
load is this but instead of reading the
JSON file sitting in data Lake I'm
reading the interim schema I got
populated in the previous job now in
here it's also very similar I'm just
calling instead of standardized I'm
calling process dim parking Bay data and
so on and I'm writing out to the data
warehouse tables right here that's for
my dimension tables and I'm doing
exactly the same with my fact tables so
very standard very simple transformation
logic right here and finally I have a
stored procedure call within data
factory where I'm calling a stored
procedure
called load data warehouse so let's have
a look at that the load data warehouse
sort procedure looks like this it's very
simple so I'm just truncating my
dimension tables and reloading it but
why via an insert into select star from
external table right so it the logic is
quite simple the magic here is that
external table
what is this external table so if you've
ever used poly base this should look
quite familiar an external table is
essentially a pointer to files in data
link so you can see that I'm creating
and the definition of this external
table is I'm saying data source data
leak storage which I've defined which
has all the credentials that it needs to
connect to that specific instance and
I'm saying look for my data in this
location so let's have a look at that
location that location in data Lake is
essentially these these are my parka
files these are the files that underpin
the sparks equal tables that I've
inserted in my previous transform job so
if sparks equal tables all of all is
just a metadata pointer to the files
that's actually sitting in data Lake
okay so once that's run we have data and
just a select star and there goes
there's my fact table data cool so I'll
just jump back to the presentation
okay so that wasn't great eat anything
groundbreaking that's a relatively
straightforward pipeline and to be fair
to the modern data warehouse pattern
this is this pattern has been proposed
by Microsoft for the past few years now
the common question and the common thing
that folks and clients that I have
worked with that have trouble with is
how do you operationalize this how do we
move that entire thing to another
environment and the standard answer is
okay so let's let's dig in deeper than
just rubbing some DevOps on it so DevOps
essentially is the union of people
process and product now this talk is a
little bit focused on the product but
the people in process parts this is
definitely very important and integral
to the DevOps process and ultimately
it's about doing the continuous delivery
of value to your end-users how can we
accelerate this value to the end-users
through potentially tools like CI CD and
so on like the way I like to think about
DevOps and this is actually based on
this blog post right here in the Lincoln
outpost apply the slides up so you can
have a read but essentially I like the
way they describe it here where you
think of the data pipeline as a value
pipeline right it's taking raw data raw
data sets and then converting them into
valuable assets that your users can use
so in a way it's like it's the
continuous delivery of value in your
data your data Factory is a pipeline
that continuously delivers value to your
end-users however this is not the only
pipeline we have a second pipeline
called the innovation pipeline and this
is the pipeline that essentially updates
your value pipeline so that any ideas
that your your data analyst or a data
engineers have can be deployed into
production and then be used by your
value pipeline to produce the best value
for your users now there's a bit of
duality here because you'll do
orchestrators you have the orchestrator
for your pipeline and you have the
orchestrator
for your innovation pipeline so and
along with your testing right so your
test you have to test both your data and
your pipeline for your value pipeline
your data is changing but your value
pipeline is not well your innovation
pipeline your data is fixed you're
giving a fixed data while your
innovation pipeline is changing so
there's a there's a little bit
complications of when you think about it
and just have to remember which part are
you testing and which part which
pipeline are you actually orchestrating
for the innovation pipeline I'm using
Azure pipelines as my CI CD mechanism
and Azure pipelines is part of the
bigger as your dev books suite for
example a few boards and repost expense
and artifacts all of this is available
natural DevOps but we'll be focusing
specifically just an ad your pipelines
okay so going back to our little
architecture there's really three
components really here that we need to
automate we have the data bricks jobs
right here your transformation your
notebooks and that package that I was
loading we have sequel data warehouse
which have all your sequel schema your
your the stored procedures and all that
sort of stuff and then you have your
actual pipeline the data factory
pipeline itself let's go through one of
them at a time so the first thing I want
to focus is your add your data breaks
now if you remember in the demo I showed
you that one line of code which I was
importing that package that's actually
quite fundamental in the way you
structure your data transformation code
so data transformation codes belong in
packages not in notebooks now this might
seem obvious this is the folks coming
from a software engineering background
but it's very common at least from my
experience to see you know thousands of
lines of code in a notebook and it's
very difficult to write unit tests if
your code is in a notebook so my advice
to lots of folks when I see this is you
want to really think about your
transformation logic what which are
really specific to transformation and
which is specific to dowel or data
access code and you rip out your
transformation code and put it in a
package that it's now encapsulated where
you can just call those functions within
your notebook that way you can actually
write proper unit tests against your
transformations
and data bricks also comes with the
integrated version control mechanism so
you can wire up your notebook so that it
wires up to get github add your DevOps
or bitbucket and it also comes with this
good CLI so that you can automate
different steps within your workspace or
management of your workspace so let's
have a look at what that looks like so
I'm gonna jump into Visual Studio code
and Visual Studio core vs code and this
is basically my Python package so you
can see that I have my functions my get
scheme and my standardized parking Bay
data and all of that has all the SPARC
code encapsulated within it along with
my validation code that way I can
actually I can actually call and run my
unit tests so I have a make file here
the make file has just basically
simplified the way I've run my tests I
can just simply say make tests so I'll
just run that here and this goes and
triggers all my unit tests so the unit
test looks like this I'm simply
instantiating a spark session locally
and spark is open source right spark can
be installed locally in your box it
doesn't you don't need to have a data
breaks cluster running and then I'm
simply calling I'm just simply reading a
known data set that's saved locally
calling my function and then doing some
asserts so now all of a sudden I can
actually write proper unit tests against
my my data transformation code okay and
the other thing I wanted to show you is
in data breaks you can actually
integrate your notebook with source
control so there's two ways to actually
bring down your files through your to
look to your local computer one is you
can just simply export it that's the
manual way or you can click on revision
history and then you can link it to get
so I haven't linked this because I used
a different way and you just simply add
your details over here and to link to
your relevant git repo the way I like to
do it and this is more of a personal
preference than anything else is I just
use the data break CLI so the data break
CLI you can
do a data breaks workspace export dear
and it will export down your notebooks
locally and I also use a data break CLI
in my CI CD pipelines to actually
automate importing this into the
workspace when I go into staging ok
next sequel data warehouse so as there's
this really wonderful tool called sequel
server data tools and what this tool
does is that it allows developers or
data engineers to pull down your
database objects locally and not only
that you can also do a schema compare
such that if anyone does some
development on sequel server management
studio or someone changes the table
definition you can do a schema compare
to your local instance or local code
base and it will pull down the diff
between what is deployed in your server
and what is what you have locally then
you can actually generate something
called a DAC back and the DAC pack is
this nice package you can use to deploy
and point to a different server it will
incrementally update that server based
on the diff between the DAC pack and
what's deployed in that server it comes
to the CLI I do want to point out that
the sequel data warehouse support is
still in preview so just just take a
note of that but sequel address equal
database has been supported in GA for
for many years now so let's have a look
quickly look at sequel data tools so I'm
gonna jump into Visual Studio so this is
actually a visual visual Student it
comes out-of-the-box with Visual Studio
2019 and I believe in 2017 you have to
download the latest for sequel data
warehouse support and you can see here
that all my definite my sequel database
objects are in Visual Studio so all of
my sword' procedures my table
definitions and so on and if I want to
update the if let's say someone created
the table so for in this case I created
a sample table in my dev database I can
just do a schema compare and click
compare and it will detect that someone
created this database and I can just
click update and this will update this
definitions locally so it's a very
really powerful way of making sure that
you have the latest version of your
sequel server objects in source control
and other cool thing about this is
verify if I do a build this will try to
validate of all my objects so if you
ever done database development and
you're in a stored procedure which
reference a table and someone dropped a
column
yours that's not yours es SMS is not
gonna complain and you'll find out later
in production that your stored
procedures referencing a column that no
longer exists however here when I do a
build and that column doesn't exist it
will tell me that oh hey your stored
procedures not consistent you need to
update your stored procedures so just
simply doing a build is actually
incredibly powerful that build produces
what I mentioned earlier is your DAC
pack file and this DAC pack file is what
I'm going to be used seeing in my CIC
pipeline to deploy to my stage and my
production environments okay so coming
back to the slides so the next thing
that I want to focus on is data Factory
so data factory also comes with its own
and get integration so as you can see
here it integrates with github or Azure
DevOps repos out-of-the-box and you can
just select your github account what
repository the collaboration branch
which is essentially which branch can
you publish changes to your factory that
it's linked to and which folder you want
actually pulled or saved the artifacts
that data/factory creates
oops sorry
okay once you've actually wired up
data/factory this is the the recommended
way of actually using the artifacts or
the flow that you would undertake to do
CI CD using your data the in artifacts
within data factory so typically you
would create your data factory that's
synced to a dead branch your which is
which we call the working branches and
once you're happy you do a pull request
to master and this is essentially your
collaboration branch this is the branch
where you can publish changes to your
Deb breath your Deb factory now your dev
factory then once you publish the
changes you're dead factory sinks
automatically the arm templates for this
data factory into a publish branch this
publish branch by default is called a DF
publish and this a DF publish has your
arm templates which we you can then use
as an artifact to your release
definition when you create a release you
just pick up these arm templates and
then parameterize them with the correct
parameters and you can deploy these arm
templates the relevant environments such
as test or prod or pre prod and so on so
let's have a look at what that looks
like so I'll just jump to data factory
so I add worry I've already integrated
this pipeline but if I haven't done so
this is how you do it so you just go to
this is the landing portion of data
factory and you just click on setup code
repo and then you just click github and
then you fill up the relevant details
but once you've done that you should see
something like this so you can see that
I'm on my dev branch so any changes I do
here I it will automatically sync when I
get saved so let's have a quick change
here and say hello from NDC Sydney and
when I said save this will automatically
sync to my Deb branch so how do I want
to publish this I will then go and
create a pull request and you can see
that the pull request has detected my
change and I just go and create the pull
request I want
the politicus just yet oh I'll do that
in the later demos but I do want to show
you the other thing here which is your
master branch once I go to my master
branch this is the only branch where I
can actually publish changes into into
your deploy data Factory now the master
branch
whatever you publish from the master
branch creates this branch called ADF
publish this is your publish branch this
is automatically maintained by data
factory what is in this branch or your
arm templates so if I go into this
folder this is my arm template that I
can use the deploy data factory so those
who are not familiar with arm templates
this is essentially a Jers way of doing
infrastructure as code so it's a big
JSON file which tells exactly how to
deploy the pipeline's of your data
factory with in Azure okay so jumping
back to the slides are we done is that
all we need not yet
we smelled some configuration to do what
happens to all this connection string
right well how do you wire up all the
connection strings of data factory the
keys of data Lake and all that sort of
stuff that's when key volt comes in so
key bulb is this service and Azure where
you can use to securely store any
relevant secrets or certificates that
your applications might use the great
thing about key vault it comes with
integrations with various Azure services
one is data factory so in data factor
you can create a key boat service linked
service which can be used to pull the
secrets from keyboard and then use with
other link services for example yours
your link services which connects to
data warehouse same with data bricks you
can also create a cable back secret
scope which then is essentially a set of
secrets within a scope in in data breaks
which mirror whatever it is in keyboard
and finally in Azure in add your
pipelines you can create something
called the variable group which is also
linked to key bolt and you can bring in
secrets from key vault within a variable
group so you can use within your pipe
so let's just see how they look what
that looks like in data factory so in
data factory if I go to do my
connections you can see I have a key
vote link service this key vote link
service is referencing my cable and I've
already authenticated the MSI the manage
identity of data factory to key votes so
that it's authorized to pull the secrets
from that specific key boat so my dev
factory is authorized to pull from the
dev key boat and my stage from a stage
and so on and so forth
once that's rigged up I can simply in my
linked service for my via data factory
so this is my data warehouse leaked
service it's simply using that linked
service of Kibo and pulling down the
relevant secrets the beauty of this is
as you move across environments all you
need to do is update your key book URL
and your link service this pull
automatically the secrets relevant to
that environment as long as your secret
name is its uniform across all the
environments so it's a really elegant
way of swapping over different
environments okay so I think we are
ready to go a sample release this is how
we're gonna do it so we have a build
pipeline which is the purpose of it is
to do up doing some QA so it's running
my unit tests some linting building my
backpack building so that validates the
backpack and so on that will get
triggered on any pull request master and
then any commit the master will run the
second part of the build pipeline which
will build my backpack will bill will
create the wheel file for the Python
package along with publishing the
artifacts so my notebooks my date of my
any other scripts that's relevant to my
pipeline now this produce all produces
all the build artifacts and I'm using
also that ADF publish branch the one
with my arm templates as a build
artifacts artifact which will then feed
into my
pipeline so the release pipeline then
will deploy to stage and to prod for the
demo only deploying to stage for
simplicity purposes but you can imagine
you have a keyboard that's specific to
each environment and the pipelines will
be pulling from this cable the the
keyboard relevant to that environment
for the specific for the configurations
needed to deploy okay
so let's jump into the demo okay so I'm
gonna first show you the pipeline so
here's the pipeline that's sitting here
it's not yet running but once I go into
my pull request and actually create a
pull request and I'll say yep create a
pull request there's probably gonna be a
code review process and so on and so
forth but you can see that it's now
triggered a bunch of pipelines to
validate my PR so let's have a look at
my pipeline there should be a pipeline
coming up so you can see now it's queued
and it should be running in one second
so here it's running the first stage of
that pipeline so let's have a look at
the first day that's the validate PR
stage and it's validating my Python
packages and my sequel packages so while
that's running let's have a look at the
definition of the build artifact a build
pipeline right the build pipelines are
all defined in llamó so yeah mow it
build pipe other pipelines in the
relatively latest release you can you
can define your pipelines all in llamó
so the first job here sir first stage is
my validate PR stage let me just open it
up and you see you can see here that I
am triggering when the reason is a pull
request so only trigger this part if I'm
doing a pull request within it I have
two jobs the validate Python and
validate sequel packages so in my first
job
I am simply installing any dependencies
that my package needs to build I'm
running some linting and I'm running my
unit tests very simple now my second job
is simply doing a vs build so if you
think about it you're
to a server database project it's just a
simple visual studio project so it
follows the same pattern of actually
building it so I'm just doing a new get
restore just in case someone wants to
put nougat packages in the solution I'm
doing a build I'm doing some tests if I
have unit tests and and that's it
so that basically validates that my dad
Pat can actually build and can actually
pass the unit tests okay so I can see
that my pipeline has should be all
complete by now if not it's still
running okay let's give it a little bit
more it should be completing in the next
few seconds but let's jump first the
next next stage which is essentially
when I commit to master what will happen
so this is this is actually publishing
the artifacts now one of the most
important conditions here is you do not
want to publish artifacts unless it's
from the master branch because this is a
common thing that I find sometimes is
that you're publishing artifacts even
it's just pull requests you don't want
to do that because then you can really
create a release from unvalidated code
so you just want to publish when it's on
master and you can see I have three
other jobs here which is my Python
package my static artifacts and my
sequel packages so before I just
continue there let me just double check
okay cool that's done let me merge that
in so I have my my my pull requests have
been validated I can just merge that
pull request into master now this should
trigger the second part of the build now
once it's actually merged into master so
I am here in the pipeline on my master
branch and if I do a refresh I should
see the text pop out in the description
there you go hello from NDC Sydenham
because that's the master branch
now I'm gonna publish this this art of
this pipeline to my dev data Factory and
you can see that it's trying to figure
out the deaf and when it's not it's
figured out oh I've updated the pipeline
description I'm gonna hit okay this is
going to deploy the data factory to my
dev data factory cool and it's
generate the arm templates in the ADF
publish branch so these are the arm
templates are getting updated in that
branch the the ATF publish branch which
then I can use in my my deployment
pipelines great ok so once that's done
it should trigger the second release so
you can see that's right a second part
of my build pipeline so that's running
and within that it's running the package
the the remaining part of my build
pipeline so if I go back to my build
pipeline let's just look at what that
looks like and that's basically
essentially doing exactly the same as
the pipe the Python packages so I'm
installing installing the requirements
in order to build it I'm calling make
this my make file and a make file
basically just creates the wheel package
in Python world it's a wheel package in
dotnet world is a DLL sort of same same
analogy so that's creating the wheel
package and I'm just doing some some
simple versioning here and I'm I'm
setting the patch version as my build ID
so that so that it increments every time
I do a build and then finally I just do
a publish build artifact step which
basically publishes this as a build art
event so that's my Python package the
static artifacts is that I have the
number of others started at the
artifacts that I'll be using in my
release pack pipeline you can simply
just publish this as is so these are my
notebooks because this this data bricks
bit is mine they make the data bricks
notebooks and this one is a deployment
script that I'll be using for my data
factory publish it's a deployment ADF
it's a PowerShell script which I will be
explaining once I get to the release
part portion and then finally you have
your Seco packages so your sequel
packages this is your DAC pack so I'm
simply doing a build I am running my
tests again if just just for kicks and
then I'm finally doing a publish build
and I'm publishing that specific
backpack
okay so let's have a look at our run
okay so it's still going so you can see
in Asscher are in a DevOps you can
inspect the jobs as it runs through and
you can get all the logs as it goes as
it runs through the pipeline's
okay so once that's right I'll leave it
there for now and I will just jump back
to the slides while well that's still
running actually before I jump to the
slides let's let's actually look at the
release so I'm once this is done what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna be creating a
release so the release is now gonna pick
the artifacts that the build has created
and then publish this as as into my
stage in my prod environments so the
stage and prod environments look like
this so I have already my stage and prod
resource groups and the one that I'm
going to be publishing is the stage so
let's have a look at that and it already
has the relevant artifacts within that's
already pre deployed so you have the
data bricks workspace you'd have your
data factory and key vault and so on so
there you go so these are the we've
already have a bunch of artifacts
sitting there and this is the staging
data factory that we are publishing to
and we want to expect that once the
release completes we'll have the text
sitting here okay so let's have a look
back in there in the it's still going
it's a little slow today you see that
takes in two minutes I'll pause here
just to take any questions because we do
need to wait for this to finish to kick
off the release no questions
okay let's let's just look at the
release definition while that's going
okay so we have three stages and this is
what a release pipeline goes I'll let me
just go back one step further so if I go
to release pipeline and click Edit
you can see that I am pulling from two
artifacts for my data pipeline CI
artifact the build pipeline and also the
ADF publish branch this is my get the
ADF get get branch that I showed you
earlier
so ADF publish and then in my stage you
can create a stage this is deploying to
do the staging environment I have three
jobs or agent jobs the first agent job
deploys two data bricks
so the first step within this job I'm
simply just setting the Python version
and then I'm using I'm installing the
data brick CLI in the build agent and
then I am using the dis data break CLI
to actually upload any app library so my
wheel packaged into dbfs and then the
notebooks to my workspace so once that's
uploaded I can that essentially you've
ready deployed your notebooks and your
packages the way your data bricks
workspace actually deploys in the
correct environment is using environment
variables so here I am setting the data
bricks host and token and this host and
token basically tells the CLI which
workspace to deploy to and this
workspace and token is coming from a
bunch of variables your my build
variables or my release variables so
let's have a look at the variables here
the variables are all set in the
variables tab in Azure DevOps some of
them are not necessarily secret so I'm
just putting them straight up here in
the variables but I'm also pulling some
variables from Keeble so these are my
secrets right so two of the secrets that
I'm pulling is the domain and token this
is the host and token of my data bricks
workspace okay so let me just okay cool
the the package has been published
that's great let us now just make sure
that that's okay let's create a release
so this when you do a crate release you
can either trigger it manually and you
can select the specific version of
of the build pipeline yet you want to
actually release and you can also set up
CI CD so that once there's a new
artifacts actually available it will
trigger the release automatically now I
do find that lots of folks that I work
with typically want some manual or
manual steps within their release you
can definitely put some manual
validation gates so that it blocks in
certain stages for someone to actually
verify the release as it's actually good
so let me create that release and that
would go and queue up the release so
let's just jump back to the release
pipeline now the second part of the
release pipeline so we've talked about
the data breaks bit the second part is
data factory so data factory is your
just standard arm template right so the
arm template deployment resource arm as
your resource group deployment task is
perfectly suitable for this this
basically takes the arm template that we
that's produced by the ABF publish and
deploys it to a relevant resource group
in this case the staging resource group
the most important part of this is
essentially this guy you want to
override the template parameters right
so you want to make sure that you're
actually overriding that the parameters
in your arm template that was pointing
to dev and make sure that you're
actually pointing to staging so once
you've override the parameters to the
correct data factor it should deploy to
that environment yes
yep so this this guy incremental so
incremental means it will always do an
incremental change it won't drop and
recreate but you can change that to
complete which will drop and recreate
obviously exactly so you do not want to
do a complete because this it will drop
whatever is in that resource group and
make sure it conforms to that arm
template right okay and this other steps
that your that I've added here which
I've haven't really talked about this
one basically just stops in and restarts
a trigger because there's this work and
data factory where you can't deploy to
an existing data factory if you have
then stopped the triggers so you need to
manually or code encode manually stop
the triggers deploy your data factory
and then restart the trigger so that's
what that PowerShell script was doing in
my build by plane that PowerShell script
by the way is available in Azure dogs so
I just in the tree just copy paste in it
so they they they know that this
scenario exists so they've provided it
to everyone and lastly we have the
backpack task so the backpack task as
you imagine I'm taking that backpack and
just using that and deploying it to the
relevant server now this backpack the
cool thing here is that you can override
or you can set variables that are
parameterize your DAC pack deployments
so in this case I'm a mature eyes the
ABL s location and credential so just if
I just look into my into what that looks
like in my script
I've actually parameterised this
location setting in my external data
source that way I can pass the parameter
when I deploy and it will it will point
in the relevant data Lake okay so I am
hoping that my release pipeline is
almost done
but if it's not that's okay I I have one
last thing to show which i think is
still very important and I lots of
people kind of miss is monitoring so
monitoring I know lots of people like to
focus on the CI CD bit when we talk
about DevOps but monitoring is just an
important in fact I think
when you go into production this will be
the most important thing that you can
actually have so you want to monitor
your infrastructure pipeline and data
don't forget your data as your monitor
is this all Ingham very very
feature-rich monitoring suite on Azure
it comes with all of this services here
and I obviously don't have talked time
to talk about everything but I will be
focusing on how you actually monitor
your data because this is something that
lots of people kind of miss so while my
release is still going let's jump to
monitoring and I'll just go to my
notebook again and I didn't scroll all
the way to the end because there's this
metrics piece of code right here this
metrics piece of code is using app
insight so I'm instantiating an
telemetry client using the app insights
library and then I'm doing a count on
the data frames that I've loaded that
way I can track how many records I've
loaded and expose this in a dashboard
now you can add even more sophisticated
monitoring for example are there nulls
what's that what's the average of this
this column and so and so forth right
and then you can send that to
application insights as a metric and
then you can then post this in the
dashboard so that you can know if
there's bad data coming in I I would I
would also definitely track my malformed
count so if that goes up you can send an
alert if we all of a sudden you have a
spike in bad rows that's coming through
your pipe so once you've set that up
this will run every time your notebook
job runs then you can just navigate to
application inside so this is
application insights and if I go to the
metric namespace and you can see I have
a custom metric namespace right here I'm
just gonna go select that and all my
metrics that I'm capturing is available
here for me to chart so if I go here as
I want to do a bar chart and I'll make
it sum of all the records that's been
loaded in the past every run and you can
see there's they're slowly adding new
dimensions to my dimension tables and I
can just simply tell pin that to my
current dashboard and if I view my
dashboard this is what
site so I have my row counts of the
different dimensions and this is the new
thing that I pinned so you can
definitely build sophisticated
dashboards using the azure monitor suite
the other thing that I quickly want to
show you is you can also use cousteau so
once you have your data factory so this
is my data factory you can go to
diagnostic settings go to diagnosis
settings and you can enable diagnostic
settings here and send your diagnostic
settings to log analytics now once you
have your logs flowing in to add your
data into log analytics you can use
cousteau which is a query language
available in Azure ledger log analytics
to actually write sophisticated queries
to expose this into your dashboard so
this is a relatively simple query but
you can you get the gist so I'm just
some I'm just filtering the logs based
on my specific resource and I'm just
doing a group by in cousteau it's called
summarize count by level and level is
the type of log in this case I don't
have any errors it's all informational
logs but if there were error so it's
gonna show up here and it will I can
then post this into my dashboard which
I've already done so this is basically
saying that should be a pie chart but I
think it's my browser resolution is kind
of screwing up with the rendering but
that should be a pie chart saying 72
Gudrun's have been performed okay so I
am hoping my release pipeline okay cool
it's done
so now if I navigate to my staging data
factory so this is my staging data
factory and if i refresh this refresh
this I have hello from NEC Sydney cool
deploy two-stage awesome alright so just
to summarize the key learnings is you
want to validate early your pipeline
push your validation right before you
hit your silver silver tier data sets
ensure your data pipeline is replayable
1/8 aka you want to build idempotent
pipelines you because you know things
will go wrong you will want to be able
to replay your pipelines ok
the first one was leverage data tearing
in the data late and automate your
deployment pipelines now there's an
asterisk here because I know certain
organizations want some manual steps
manual validation Sept and that's
totally fine with if that's their
process but it's definitely good if you
have at least a run sheet or a csv
pipeline to get you partial to the all
the way or at least 90% of the way
ensure your data transformation code
accessible so you can write proper unit
tests secure and centralize your
configuration and last but not the least
is monitoring infrastructure pipelines
and data all the artifacts that I've
shown here is available in my github you
can just go to github dev lace data
DevOps and all of that I've shown
including some deployment scripts arm
templates notebooks Python packages are
all in here and that is my talk so if
you can reach me Twitter or you can
navigate to github I do have other demos
in github if you're interested and with
that I think I have around five minutes
for questions
yes set okay that's a good question
so this talk has been in the making for
the past few months but I it's not like
I've been working on it you know 24 you
know every every day on this talk so I
actually gave an iteration of this talk
maybe in July and in May but it was a
much shorter talk so I've really built
out those artifacts maybe in total I'd
say a week or two of work mostly because
the the transformation logic was fairly
simple and if you're familiar with the
services it should be relatively it's
just an exercise I'm just sending it up
right so I think the biggest roadblock
to this is there's so many moving parts
and there's so many different services
that's involved that every one of them
if you haven't played with it will there
will have a learning curve so that's
probably what if you're familiar with
already the individual parts putting
down together shouldn't be that painful
any other questions no well lastly
please make sure to put a green post-it
as you go out if not let me know give me
some feedback what can be better with my
talk which reach out to me and Twitter
but with that thank you all for coming
and I hope you enjoyed your talk the dog
[Applause]